Вони літають на передовій і за "нулем",
прикривають піхоту і знищують ворожу техніку.
Це льотчики армійської авіації, яка належить до Сухопутних військ України.
На передньому краї вони виконують вогневі задачі і десантно-транспортні.
На даний час ми комбінуємо, тобто виконуємо і ті, і ті.
Усім відомі завдання - десантно-транспортні польоти на "Азовсталь".
Цим вирізнилися наші льотчики армійської авіації з усіх сторін.
Це леви!
Тут нема з ким порівняти: ні з одним льотчиком, ні з одною армією світу.
Вертолітники надають підтримку саме сухопутним силам.
Вони забезпечують авіаційну підтримку піхоті:
коли вона йде в наступ - прикривають з повітря.
Коли в наступ іде ворог - знищують його техніку і особовий склад.
Вертоліт - це як та ж артилерія, тільки вона мобільна.
Тобто, наприклад, на якійсь ділянці фронту йде або наступ наших, або прорив ворога.
І треба в цю хвилину, за пів години, за годину надати артилерійську допомогу.
І вертоліт з цим дуже класно справляється.
Тобто ми надаємо цю підтримку відразу.
Бо, наприклад, те саме, що в нас є на озброєнні - "Град" -
йому треба доволі багато часу, щоб з однієї точки
переміститись на іншу і виконати те саме завдання,
що ми виконуємо. Тільки велика різниця в часі.
Вони працюють 24/7 і в будь-яку хвилину готові вилетіти на допомогу.
Та кожен політ - це величезний ризик.
Основна небезпека для вертольотів - це ворожа ППО і піхота.
Тому пілоти переважно літають низько над землею,
щоб зменшити ймовірність бути виявленими
та ураженими із ворожих зенітно-ракетних комплексів.
Саме тому ми літаємо так низько, щоб ворожа піхота не мала змоги нас виявити.
Якщо вони нас побачать, вони будуть мати змогу навестися і здійснити пуск ракети.
І це становить для нас небезпеку.
Саме тому також є великі ризики від їхніх винищувачів,
які складають для нас небезпеку.
Бо вони мають змогу наводитися з повітря.
У них більш сучасні літаки, більш сучасне обладнання на них.
Вони нас можуть виявляти, захоплювати нас і навіть виконувати пуски ракет.
Тому це також становить небезпеку для нас.
Через застарілі радянські системи льотчики не бачать, коли на них наводяться.
Ті системи, які зараз стоять на наших гелікоптерах, вони трошки застарілі.
І кожен політ - це дуже великий ризик.
Тому, що ми не бачимо, чи наводиться на нас той чи інший засіб ПЗРК,
чи світить нас якийсь там літак-винищувач противника.
Ми цього не бачимо.
А на нових вертольотах закордонного зразка -
вони всі обладнані цими системами.
Тобто кожен політ, по факту, це дуже великий ризик.
Бойовий вертоліт тому і називається бойовим,
тому що він має захищені частини, які могли би захистити його.
У нашому випадку найбільша загроза для вертольотів - це ракети.
При влучанні ракети цей вертоліт наповнений всюди авіаційним керосином.
І тому він спалахує миттєво.
У випадку ж використання новітніх вертольотів
ми мали би можливість збільшити шанс екіпажу вижити у випадку такої ситуації.
Оскільки на таких вертольотах ці відсіки йдуть захищеними.
І вони збільшують живучість екіпажу.
Зараз на озброєнні армійської авіації - лише радянські гелікоптери Мі-24, Мі-8 і Мі-2.
Зараз Мі-24 і Мі-8 виконують однакові задачі в плані нанесення вогневого ураження.
А гелікоптери Мі-8 також виконують і десантно-транспортні задачі.
Тобто Мі-8 зараз виявився набагато функціональнішим.
Але в плані нанесення вогневого враження Мі-24 - це, звичайно, такий собі літаючий танк.
Та, за словами льотчиків, їм необхідне оновлення авіапарку.
Через нестачу ударних вертольотів їм доводиться використовувати транспортні під час бойових дій.
Мі-8 сам по собі - це транспортний вертоліт,
але в силу своєї уніфікованості він може використовуватися
як і в санітарному варіанті, так і в бойовому варіанті.
Нам пощастило, що цей вертоліт багатофункціональний,
і ми його можемо використовувати в бойовому варіанті.
Саме тому тут встановлені боки з некерованими ракетами,
які ми використовуємо для бойового застосування.
Такі некеровані авіаційні ракети вражають так звані площинні цілі -
скупчення військ чи техніки.
Від них не можна очікувати точного потрапляння - основне ураження йде від уламків.
Це некерована авіаційна ракета. Цей блок.
Це основний тип озброєння, який зараз застосовується на вертольотах.
Але в той же час більш новітні вертольоти дали б нам можливість
використовувати саме керовані авіаційні ракети
і збільшили б наші бойові можливості.
Яких саме західних бойових вертольотів потребує армійська авіація?
Чого потребує наша армійська авіація?
Це більш ударних вертольотів, таких як Viper, таких як Super Cobra.
Десантно-транспортні задачі можуть виконувати такі, як UH-60.
"Падіння Чорного Яструба", я думаю, всі дивилися,
всі знають, що це за вертольоти.
І Apache - це був би взагалі ідеальний варіант.
Можливо, не найбільш новітньої комплектації, це зрозуміло
, а того, що вони вже не використовують так сильно,
але вони могли б підсилити нашу армію.
Західні бойові вертольоти мають потужніші маневрувальні і швидкісні характеристики,
а також кращі засоби ураження, на відміну від радянських.
Це треба порівняти. От, наприклад, наша авіаційна техніка,
наші вертольоти і західного зразка - це як "Жигулі" і новий "Мерседес".
Якість виконання завдання буде в рази більша, ніж те, що ми виконуємо зараз.
Ми від цієї техніки витискаємо все, що від неї можливе і неможливе.
Ми стараємося виконувати, попадаємо, все в нас добре,
але, наприклад, за той самий період часу на західній техніці
ми можемо знищити більше ворога.
І це буде більш ефективніше, ніж, наприклад, от, ми виконуємо зараз.
Поки ж західні партнери, переважно зі Східної Європи,
віддають Україні свої вертольоти Мі-17 або Мі-35, замінюючи їх на сучасніші зразки.
Ці гвинтокрили за характеристиками схожі на ті, що є в Україні, тільки більш модернізовані.
Один американський вертоліт Black Hawk є в арсеналі ГУР.
Зараз чехи разом зі словаками збирають кошти на ще один такий.
А от про перемовини щодо передачі Україні сучасних західних гелікоптерів інформації наразі немає.
Експерти вважають, що це питання точно не найближчого року,
адже такі гелікоптери дуже дорогі
і, поки Україна не має переваги на полі бою
і достатніх можливостей прикриття з неба,
будуть зручною ціллю для ворога.